vous voulez partir votre propre podcast
vous voulez à mener celui que vous avez
déjà un autre niveau
ça tombe bien on loue le studio sf ce
merveilleux studio dans lequel je suis
présentement et dans lequel également on
enregistre le sans filtre podcast parmi
tant d'autres la plupart du temps ce qui
empêche les gens de sauter dans
l'univers du podcast est en croissance
constante c'est le manque de
connaissances techniques et aussi le
manque de matériel d'un qu'à cela ne
tienne dans le studio sf on loue le
studio avec tout le matériel donc tous
les micros tous les caméras si vous
voulez faire une version vidéo de votre
podcast et ça vient aussi avec notre
technicien extraordinaire nicholl
nicholl qui va vous guider dans votre
projet c'est probablement la personne au
québec qui écoutent le plus de balados
indépendant parce qu'ils derrière la
console surtout les balados qu'on
enregistre au studio sf donc il va se
faire un plaisir de vous accompagner
dans ce processus là si vous voulez plus
d'information au sujet de la location du
studio écrivez nous à sans filtre
podcast à commercial gmail.com
une production du studio sfr bienvenue
ou sans filtre le podcast on parle de ce
qu'on veut avec nos invités dati sytjus
ph quentin avec moi d'une plante
cette semaine on n'a pas de nom sort un
petit mot rapide sur vegan n'est pas
plate encore une fois on livre des mains
surgelés à votre porte on est allé
porter 25% nous profite au chum
ça faisait quand même des plots pas mal
ce qui me suivent sur instagram vous
avez ce possible puis l'on donne 25 %
pour la deuxième phase 25% nous profite
à des banques alimentaires
donc si vous voulez avoir des plans
complètement savoureux livré chez vous
triple w point vmp points 6 à l'échec et
ça ça vaut vraiment la peine et effectue
cette semaine dans le sang cette semaine
on a reçu un grand plaisir de recevoir
un ancien joueur de national les
canadiens du wild de minnesota guillaume
latendresse un chic type 1 go
ce qui est drôle qui est gentil si qui
phonique des histoires à l'infini on a
parlé de son nouveau podcast la poche
bleus qui vient tout juste de commencer
ces quelques épisodes qui sont sortis
trois ou quatre c'est super le fun y ait
des invités des anciens joueurs la
nationale les joueurs qui jouent encore
les athlètes d'autres de d'autres sports
il ya urgence saint pierre martin
brodeur son podcast
c'est vraiment le fun ii d'entendre
dégâts par les dents tandis que qui ont
convaincu la game de l'intérieur
raconter des histoires ensemble
d'échanger là dessus si c'est par le
connecter même pour moi qui étais un non
connaisseur des rocky sinon on a parlé
aussi de développement d'athlètes de
jeunes d'éviter lui sont d'opinion en
fait ce qu'il faut pour surspécialisés
les jeunes trop tôt faut les développer
vraiment les renforts enfin plusieurs
sports alors faire jouer plusieurs
positions dans leur sport à faire
essayer toutes sortes d'affaires avoir
de plus tard ceux spécialisés qui on a
parlé aussi des commotions cérébrales
qui quelque chose que qui guillaume doit
doit vivre avec maintenant lui fait
plusieurs commissions salaire un peu
coupé plus court sa carrière finalement
donc quoi faire en cas de commotions
comment éviter ce commun que commet
aussi chez les jeunes on doit les
éduquer pour que ça arrive - lens fabre
conversation puis je m'achète un sujet
quand même difficile pour lui de parler
mais il est très généreux et très gentil
de vouloir quand même à bord du sujet
puis j'ai l'impression que c'est quand
même important pas d'en parler pour
qu'il puisse avoir du changement de haut
niveau de plus de prévention niveau des
commissions dont le taux exact qui était
guillaume il était super candidat de
l'entendre sa conversation puis c'est
vraiment le fun de voir ça sa perception
parce que moi et en flandre ok j'avais
suivi sa carrière de l'extérieur puis
j'entends des justes les échos de des
médias c'était vraiment intéressant
n'entendent plus profondément qu'est-ce
que comment lui l'avait vécu en fait le
fait que ce soit pour la conversation
sinon impétueux nous est-ce que vous
pouvez nous encourager en ce moment on
essaie de faire des podcasts exclusif
aux membres pétrole juste de mémoire ou
est-ce qu'on jase dernièrement on est
allé un petit peu gg tendue vers le
la théorie du complot si vous voulez
aller voir écouter ça les laitiers qui
s'assure pétrone évidemment on met pas
en ce moment d'absolument mais toutes
les podcasts en exclusivité sur pickton
maintenant on l'aimé pas parce qu'on
enregistre vraiment juste avant que ça
sorte pour tout le monde pour essayer de
rester à l'affût de l'actualité
mais aussitôt que la vie va reprendre
son cours puis qu'on va pouvoir rouvrir
le studio pourrait avoir des podcasts en
banque on va mettre tous les podcasts là
dessus donc c'est la meilleure façon
nous encourager sinon abonnez vous à
toutes nos chaînes
laissez-nous des commentaires
laisse-nous waiting sur les applications
balado ça fait son bout de chemin depuis
sans plus attendre bonne conversation
bonne écoute
[Musique]
yes fait que guérir merci d'avoir
accepté notre invitation pour venir sur
le podcast le plaisir les boys avec la
femme le thème un nouveau nouveau rose
dans l'univers du podcast québécois ça
fait ça fait un petit bout que que je
parle à domme justement tu fais qui a
pas de podcasts de deux ans quéro cité
par des anciens gaudelas du show au
québec puis puis je trouve que vous
tombez lapointe
ouais mais c'est un peu mais ça fait
longtemps que j'ai ressenti clooney main
de fer par cas ce qui est juste mattis
naud des poils des invités avec qui ça
même sur une relation où ça le flou est
moins bon mais au moins d'eau on peut
sauver une autre anecdote muscles ou ce
qu'on connaît au secours ne véhicule pas
qu'on se bagarre mais il est bâti et des
podcasts qui se font dans les sports
sont excellents qui sont super bons mais
vraiment d'avoir 2 go qui ont joué la
guigne qui sont pauvres des animateurs
de métier aussi pourquoi l'oubli fait
que les pro saleh
des moments drôles je pense que c'est ce
qu'elle mordait mans ce moment on se
prend au sérieux on s'amuse on est 12
xiam ça fait maintenant un imac son
niveau d'il y habite en allemagne qui
ont ce texte par semaine on est bien
proche récurrents se lancer là dedans
un choix osé mercredi deux semaines
bonne humeur est ce qu il veut trois
jours après qu'on ait pas de casse en
elle au bout ça a été vite alors vous
avez vous avez des goûts du monde nous a
fait grincer des dents mais aussi des
personnalités du monde les gens ont un
goût d'entendre parler métier je veux
pas avoir maintenant je donne un exemple
michel therrien il m'a dit c'est quoi
son city je veux savoir d après des
années c'est ce que pour aller chercher
ces gars du synode couleurs sens que
c'est un pas de casse ou on parle aux
gens c'est des questions dans une
conversation pin vert no 2 mondial des
produits québécois
c'est sûr on veut pas que si le quai
pour ramener un peu le jean king et pie
x 10 km suite moi je connais focale fac
alors qu'il est si je pense jamais que
tu es une game de la lnh se complète ma
ville c'est parfait aujourd'hui les
questions vont être posées souhaité
qu'elle se sent très naïve que tu ne
connais pas ça mais moi on le ph lui qui
connaît genève le sommet si j'écoutais
deux épisodes la poche plus complet puis
même si ce n'est pas ce qui même s'il
comprend pas toutes les références des
joies de tvq parler ou dessous s'il faut
d'écouté parce que c'est décosse qui ont
dix fois d'ensemble s'est piqué puis je
te mentir on sait qu'on a une bonne
vraiment une beauté de dégâts qui
partagent cette passion leur qui
partager l'histoire ensemble qu'ils ont
du fun ensemble qui ferment c'est
vraiment le concert grenade c'est le but
qu'on voyait ce que c'est le premier
show qu'on a fait c'est mike kingsbury
georges laraque qui a dopé un choc d'une
chanter éric bélanger
il saute bien petit du corps au tessin
il viendra aussi avec max éric bélanger
c'est mon notepad il a eu à ce canal que
si on veut dire que tu peux pouvoir a
éreinté dans le premier show justement m
kingsbury centre cherchant les globes de
cristal il rappelé
romeo james hill dj pauly terre célébrée
comme tu veux pas ça nulle part puis si
max télé maintenant si je prends ma
torche est bien le vote cette semaine
georges auric année ça fait des années
on vient d'arriver de montréal les deux
mais c'est un match qui avait la
relation des dernières années c'est le
fun de voir aussi c'est moche en milieu
mais j'ai une relation qui qui avait été
peut-être perdu vingt dernières années
fait de revoir des 800 m dames
citrouilles papilles je trouve ça l'fun
les choux et les amateurs il tripote
honnêtement pas qu'ils n'ont qu'à aller
ailleurs c'est à ce moment il ya quelque
chose il ya quelque chose de vraiment
unique dans l' espèce de sentiment
d'appartenance à ce genre de
conversation là je vais je vais
expliquer un petit peu mieux ce que je
veux moi mettons le podcasting chiclets
qui est animé par rennes où est née puis
puis bissonnette d un business to
business et tisse sa hotte ressasser les
meilleurs à mon avis à moi si les
meilleures entrevues avec des joueurs de
hockey qui ce qui existe parce que quand
tu écoutes se donne l'impression de
faire partie d'un espèce de petit groupe
sélect qui qui prend connaissance de
cette conversation le tic mettons ils
l'ont fait avec sidney crosby sidney
crosby tu l'as entendu parler avec avec
la langue de bois d'un professionnel
tout le temps le tir le tutu l'oeil là
que jouer à croyons-nous whitney qui ont
des histoires de charme de joueurs ont
des histoires de souper ou est-ce qu'un
terrain est sorti sa carte de crédit qui
avait dit allez les gars et les
immeubles finalement tout le monde c'est
comme tu entends ces histoires le pit le
sentiment d'être vraiment dans un groupe
restreint l'accès à ces sur le post
c'est vraiment cool je trouve que c'est
vraiment bien ouais c'est sûr nous
autres on veut s'attarder aux débutants
ou joueurs francophones dans les gars du
québec
les anciens s'affoler mais c'est sûr que
d'aller chercher des crosby conversation
tablette beauté on veut attaquer des
gars comme ça ça c'est sur ces matchs se
jouent avec big daddy mais tarasenko ali
france éditions et des relations témoin
martin havlat télécom a l'air c'est dans
le futur sa brigade on va s'y d'attaquer
mais présente mal
l'enfer c'est vraiment tu poche bleus
est partie du panier bleus pros du
québec les biens des microbrasseries
cette chose là et on veut qu'on veut
garder ça durera le temps de continuer
dit - passé c'est par une exploration au
niveau 2 ou ce combo puisque ce qu'on
veut pas mais c'est quand même là on a
triché long et francis bouillon tillier
namur tcs été sévèrement par la
promotion désarmant l'impression va
essayer de garder la check list pour
nous autres on les regarde on suit leur
leur instinct games et puis on se lève
le matin qu'on n'est qu'à moitié se
connecte titre déjà six taurine
ces camions 800 m à 5 18 sont partout
mais est on toujours de quoi dit il ya
toujours une histoire et je n'ai pas de
par le monde dit il à différents je
pense qu'au québec on n'est peut-être
pas prête
les autres sont pas gênés là sinon c'est
à la fois peuvent fumer cigarette puis
c'est le royaume sean avery qui dit je
ne me retrouve pas les da est dit là ça
fait ça un jour je fume des cigarettes
du barousse pas jouer plus noir importe
ici comme on dit au québec ce sera pris
par tous les autres c'est juste assez
sprint s'est classé comme oublier les
cris des gens comprennent c'est quoi
qu'on fait on fait juste compter de la
samu sont beaux ils ont rythmé le
contenu qui est là dedans c'est des
anecdotes mais si rien pourquoi si on
fait pas surprendre là il mettre quelqu
un à dhamar de ces facs six coups ou
comprendre le double sens un peu comme
notre nom
une chose apparaît mais ça paraît aussi
qu'un sérieux en arrière si ça paraît
que vous avez monté mon affaire avait
plusieurs invités d'un même épisode avec
une perfo musicale avec ses puis vous
maîtrisez les lors du zoom justement de
bouger afin que ça paraît que tu
travailles pas rétif accès ce qui allait
racheter mais que c'est pas juste
les deux hommes qui s'appelle c'est
comme qui pensaient qu'ils travaillent
et par exemple mais ce qui est drôle
c'est que ces mots puis max on ne fait d
un site à g libre mais qu'aucun thème
programme de se rejoindre pour ça les
gens je me souviens de deux ou trois
extraits 100 g que max veuille ou non je
ne trouve pas braquer bâtiment les
raccrocheurs le match tu es là je te
regarde tu mets pas qu'on ait fait deux
tours d'un style puisque le monde
répondait célébrer le modem appelle donc
à croke park à ce qui connaît tout petit
mike ward et très beau bout dé racheter
cible de salut qu'à passer par jesse
james by step up et disputé sur zoom en
ce moment et si t'as pas le choix c'est
là que ça se passe d'un plafond x games
en ce moment takieddine a comme un
réalisateur en arrière et qui le lie qui
mène au spot mano photo qui fait du je
pense que du bien car ils connaissaient
rien là dedans dans la réalisation
magnifique du vainqueur sur mountain du
matin pour y voler des applications
rigoler comment ces malades tf1 qu' on
est on est chanceux parce que si c'était
c'était juste mon imac je peux dire que
le camarade tu viens dit l'autre le
premier show man ont passé d'instagram
qu'on a appelé ces malades est dit est
il qu'après il était ce mois et
fournissait pas que l'aja prochaines
heures
un papier de jardins musicaux thalbach
brise on entend des choses qu'un cousin
rempli ce qui nous a permis de grandir
[Rires]
[Musique]
pour l'instant on favorise le le québec
métier j'ai toujours pensé que si excuse
moi si le québec était un pays le québec
aurait une chance de gagner les
olympiques tu walk et le tellement
tellement le bassin de d'athlètes de
joueur de hockey québécois est imposant
pic et de qualité d'accueil d'un
dernières années c'est moins vrai de
dire qu'on aurait peut-être gagné la
médaille d'or aux olympiques mais dans
le temps que tu jouais dans league
on aurait pu gagner la médaille d'or aux
olympiques tu es fait que je dire tout
est fini du joueur le pij et non c'est
cela tue 20 dernières années ont été
vraiment solide
je ne dis pas que dit un choc on a perdu
notre naturellement québécois dans ce
sens que le développement la façon qu'on
développe on met l'emphase beaucoup trop
cela sur spécialisation des jeunes on
veut juste cent ans on est dans un sport
qu'on se concentre la petite un convoi
et que les recherches on voit des
patrons de goldman nous observons dans
plusieurs domaines touchant cuiseaux
font en sorte que tout est bon dans la
coordination des mains des yeux les
pieds des outils ces choses là que c'est
plus difficile à acquérir dans leur ok
mais tu peux le pas dans d'autres
or choc en ce moment on se trompe au
niveau de notre développement
il était sur l'évaluation du
développement à long terme du joueur qui
sort vraiment ciblé loge de 7 à 12 ans
ou ce que ces lits les années un peu
primaire et partant que les plus grosses
années du développement de l'athlète une
joute des six en rien leur enlever parce
que c'est des bénévoles qui font le
travail exceptionnel mais on n'a pas
d'argent pour avoir des entraîneurs de
qualité dans ces années-là fax nos
jeunes en leur année les plus grandes
pour se développer sont coachés par papa
et maman qui n'ont jamais joué
probablement puis qui font des pratiques
indignes csst c'est plate que je dis
mais c'est ça quand même je pense qu'on
a une façon de revoir tout ce qu'on doit
aller s'attaquer à nos jeunes
un démarrage beaucoup plus jeunes pour
leur permettre de mener deux meilleurs
joueurs de main aux athlètes du monde
c'est cool c'est pertinent en fait la
sueur spécialisation parce que si tu
donnes pas tout le monde comme exemple
qui aurait très bien pu jouer au
basketball au collégial il y aurait très
bien peu de draft et dans nba irait très
bien putté toutes ces gueux la même
chose pour lebron james qui aurait très
bien pu jouer au football aux jo et
ouais exact exact qui est allé jouer
promotrice bolt littéralement souhaite
en milieu de carrière mais puis à plus
petite échelle puis évidemment à moins
grande qualité moi j'ai fait ça au site
j'ai joué au hockey pendant huit ans
pendant que je faisais de la natation
puis c'est sûr ça l'a aidé ma natation
là c'est sûr sûr sûr sûr sûr sûr loin
tout est ce que tu fais du sport 4
étaient aussi les plus jeunes moi j'ai
tout fait laisse pas honnêtement je joue
ça que je joue au baseball mais je t'ai
je peux pas dire que c'est un athlète un
joueur de hockey
j'ai fait d'autres sports qui m'ont aidé
mais j'ai jamais été passionné par
d'autre part j'ai jamais trouvé mon bon
sport qu'à la faire en sorte que bongo à
l'été je fais seule image face au pcf
mauger et et ça fait plaisir on sait que
ce n'est dernières années qu'on commence
à réaliser ces mots jetés sans éclat ce
onze mois par année comment j'allais
même si je pense qu'il ya un groupe par
exemple de jeunes de passionnés qui doit
peut-être plus talentueux qui peuvent se
permettre d'être à l'année peut-être un
peu plus que certains autres qui ont
besoin de développer des
caractéristiques de important de joie
intime sur moi je me suis retrouvé les
cédantes mes années de rock et j'ai
jamais joué mon niveau j'ai toujours été
surclassés
je me suis retrouvé à jouer toujours
delajoux l'été c'est ici dans mon année
de 3 dt ont joué le jeu pense que je
regarde ton ses jeunes joueurs
3 dt on n'avait pas une game 1 1 3 4
je pense qu'on a eu huit ou neuf joueurs
qui ont joué puis je pense projetaient
les plus que ceux qui ont joué aux
professionnels ces gros ledentu 3 dt de
jeunes de 12 13 ans y en a huit
neuf ou dix qui ont joué du hockey
professionnel c'est énorme c'est dans
mon année mais oui cm3 collège charles
lemoyne d'années qu'on égorgeait quand
j'ai joué à 14 ans - frédéric st denis
qui est armé choo les trous on ne joue
la ligue nationale trois hommes et du
trot de la même année droit sur une
équipe c'est énorme énorme en ce moment
c'est 1 2 3 dans l'igloo cefac faut
trouver une façon de ramener sur ce que
l'on avait été mon frère joue
professionnels it enhanced est question
de beaucoup de gars ont réussi à
développer du joueur de hockey
je trouve qu'on a perdu notre façon de
faire ok oui on se concentre c'est moi
je suis un gros sur le sur le l'égalité
au niveau du temps de glace ben gros sur
le développement de joueurs je pense
qu'on est on se concentre trop sur les
jeunes les meilleurs jeunes à 14 à 15 à
13 ans quand je regarde les tendances
d'eau qui le je m'excuse l'homme et
développement du joueur se fait beaucoup
plus tard il se fait plus jeunes au
niveau des attitudes mais au niveau du
développement il ya des late bloomer les
dégâts 17-18 qui peuvent encore être
très bonne entrée jeudi à majorque sauf
que ici sont probants à king size merci
bonsoir mon chambre sans jouer dans une
ligue tu vois les fantaisies de suite
pas passer dix jours le duo qui est je
pense qu'on fait une erreur parce que
des joueurs qui on oublie qu'ils perdent
leur un petit peu fou faut essayer de
remanier sa hauteur plus jeune que
pluvieux pour et d'essayer s'y connaît
un peu moi c'est celle là dessus je me
bats au dessus c'est sûr qu'avant les
autres s'étaient pas mis trio dans une
game étroite jouets 18-22 menottes à
quatrième ligne jouets 3,4 à une réalité
en 2020 un peu plus facile pour que plus
facile par un pays mais 500 places pour
jouer chez nous tout de suite donner au
moins un minimum de temps gasmi lui
permettre d'avoir au moins une éclosion
darron opportunité de chat est née
l'idée de créer un esprit d'équipé un
esprit de vos petits instants la passion
est beaucoup moins grand que ce qu'on
faisait dans nos années un douar en
ligue 1 évidement je dois hockey y
arrivait chez eux et regardaient le
canadien y regarder notre élite on
faisait le jeu ok si on ne te prends un
joueur qui fait d'avoir joué dans la rue
la station y ait trop de choses auto a
qui ont perdu de cette passion leurs
actes en deux parties trois hauts cadres
dans une équipe de 18 20 qui sont
vraiment des passionnés de la guigne
facs je pense que ça aussi ça peut jouer
dans l'aspect de développement parce que
on réalise pas à quel point de
maintenant moi je suis bien et gros sur
le vidéo individuel le petit bureau de
voir tous ces bouts de phrases il ya ici
en échec avant ce tableau tout on a un
nom c'est important de devoir le faire
l'erreur d'un port tapis bonjour de la
voix mais de l'avoir s'indigne de suite
kate a fait parce que c'est notre job
dit montrer ses erreurs techniques de
développement on est là pour développer
et on veut tellement axée sur les
résultats
au lieu d'aller sur le processus sur la
façon droite sur le développement de
joie qu'ont les chapes totalement ce
moment pour moi car il mais si je me
trompe
moi j'ai l'impression qu'ils aiment et
ont des gueux qui vont être dans le 0 0
01 % qui vont se faire une place
mettons sur un premier trio dans une
échelle sur le talent aux autres
vraiment peu importe
qu'est ce qu'ils vont faire réellement
leur talent va les amener là mais j'ai
l'impression que pour toutes les autres
personnes qui se rendent à jouer
professionnel c'est beaucoup plus du
développement que tu talent du
développement je pense qu'il ya beaucoup
de développement mais une d une des plus
grosse force des geeks rang dans la
ligue nationale pour moi c'est le mental
c'est vraiment un super tu regardes
c'est cette semaine on a eu ou pas car
georges st pierre georgin pièce quand je
sonnais très professionnel dans sa
profession une écoute tu le vois la
différence entre un athlète qui endurent
champions quand t'écoutes un joueur des
ligues nationale comparativement à un
goût de la ligue américaine que
peut-être le même talent que peut-être
le même développement
je pense que l'aspect mental faire face
après si on faire face aux médias être
le douzième réussir acharné d'un gros ce
guide c'est tout c'est àdire qui en a
qui prennent la pression que tu y
arrives du mauvais sang ce qu'ils font
en sorte fij
au lieu d'apprendre de long au bord de
l'échec a trente meilleurs c'est un
point qui est très important puis moins
souvent c'est pour moi la gamme de recul
de 85% d'être socialement al haq est si
énorme c'est de dire 85e ou jouer à
montréal faisait trois quatre minutes
que je sois sa glace et jacques martel
dernier
norman semaine je me retrouve à jouer
dix jeux de 20 minutes tu pas fatigué
c'est bizarre là c'est juste le mental
j'étais bien j'étais concentré je savais
ce que je faisais c'est juste
socialement talent pour moi qui fais une
grosse puis comment ça se manifeste mais
dont le mental physiquement dans une
partie laitiers parce que c'est ça peut
être difficile de voir cette façon
concrète c c c koi mettons qui devient
le plus grand le plus grand blocage à
une performance physique quand tu parles
de mental tu penses que tu as tu peur
d'aller d'aller d'un coin tu parce que
te je sais pas tu étais plus tendue
témoins
quand tu doutes effet le gameplay du
doute en général quand tu donnes
quelqu'un qui était capable de mettre
dedans quand d'autres que tu es capable
d'aller la chercher
distin doté fin c'est sûr c'est en
vendant lecointe dix autres ont ils volé
votre procès défense en équipe une
challenge bleu
si tu doutes de la voix ressemble pas
recule faut pas prendre parce que la
confiance le mental 16 grandi c'est long
c'est long mais sa drogue dit en
tabarouette espagne match de ce que tu
aimes tard soit le petit oui et je
demande que l'état avait tabarouette
deux fois deuxième ça arrive le souci
les 50 sites là ça commence à s'éclipser
demande justement léthargie se demande
quand tu commences à douter c'est qu'un
gel est arrivé je me suis moi montréal
je recevais des gersois rondelle
pourquoi je fasse des rares mais n'ont
qu'à me voyant dans et puis en y
indiquant le niveau cela gagne donc on
va emmener avec moi ma structure gère la
situation les chars de moine ici qu'il a
sous la grâce à ce rapport fait pas
d'erreurs ça va racheter d'ici prend des
décisions si ça ne se la guerre s'est
basé sur le modèle suédois si on dit
toujours aux jeunes sita rondelle et
papa sow barroso ne soit coupée non
connaît les conséquences évalue la le
pourcentage de réussite prend la
décision
si tu le fais couper mais après son vote
reprendront leur baguette créa décision
on
vienne est convoqué ce qu'on peut faire
le prochain coup c'est quoi tes autres
options pour avoir pour prendre de
meilleures décisions
donc si c'est niaiseux mais juste de
dire fait perso ou à comparer prend la
décision
c'est du négatif converse en positif qui
permet aux jeunes une attitude puis un
épanouissement au mot que je trouve qui
est énorme avec une zone savoir partir
des prochaines semaines l'australien
tech de ces gènes tu sais si tu y vas je
prends décision c'est ce fait ces
logements avoir l'impression on évalue
qu'on voit maintenant en mesure de
montrer c'est quoi les pourcentages de
chaque décision de table parce que si
j'ai la rondelle comme défenseur
l'option facile c'est quoi c'est l'heure
de jeu les jardins du plat y a pas
d'erreur c'est facile le billet post-apo
n'est ce que je me démenais que
j'utilise it en or qu'il saignait du nez
les taxes on attendait le tas donnant
aux attaques des partis c'est ça c'est
ça c'est je fasse il mais si tu veux
développer une équipe se développer des
joueurs de hockey mais il faut que tu
prennes ya pas trop de systèmes dans le
doubs où tu as cherché la poste au bord
d'être chercher n'importe quoi sauter
chercher le joaillier l'option le temps
d'une 2,3 kg à sec attraction à matonge
sans ryu qui sont fais à ma porte patine
en rondelles par une cinquième femme
prend la décision de faire ce que tu
t'arrêtes la ronde est né prend la bonne
décision selon le pourcentage que tu as
devant toi l'évaluent à mais en ne
faisant que tu va le réaliser
je suis contre le principe est mal que
j'ai raté des matchs le risque c'est
très applicable à vie en fait la même
chose qui s'est maintenu la paix
décisions qu'il faut prendre si
l'avortement par de prendre la mauvaise
décision annoncée ce midi les meilleurs
joueurs
les mains en joie secrète différence est
plus dans ton coin bon ph entre la ville
ok la seule différence c'est l'instinct
pis le temps de réaction
c'est ça la différence c'est que tu as
ton sec de ces jeunes 7.5 son comble à
prendre dans vies tous les jours
peut-être une deux ou trois secondes
pour prendre ton chemin 30a décision ou
même teinte en deux trois jours c'est
quelqu'un tu appelles tu as fait une job
une décision à prendre
metodo 3
réfléchis l'épaule et ont quatre ans
nice taxes et là c'est là que ça se
passe et c'est comme un road et c'est la
france porte et c'est là que ça se passe
à tanguer la menthe et si c'était décide
à prendre afin de mater la vie on
connaît tout le monde tellement
talentueux dans ce qu'ils font que ça
soit c'est ce qu'ils font mais si
poussée ou si vous voulez aussi l ai pas
peur mosic ça vous essayerez été défaite
si ça revient ce que tu dis
c'est dans ce port dans la vie la peur
c'est le pitbull et l'outil est peut
être le plus tard à tout le monde mais
je ne pense pas par sa part jamais ce
procès s'il ya l'aspect mental 10 85% il
la prend là dedans y'a tout ce qui vient
avec le mental c'est à fano mais aussi
et puis je pense qu'on l'oublié souvent
mais il ya 1 5% qui est le quai de la
chante c'est selon l'oublient souvent
mais pourquoi 1 go voir son opportunité
plus qu'un autre pourquoi il va avoir
une deuxième chance et nous on dit
souvent dans leurs coquilles le train
passe une fois seulement que là ça se
peut qu'ils reviennent jamais puis c'est
souvent ce qui arrive c'est mon frère
moi ya joué je vous prends le val d'or
il était capitaine d'équipé 425 points
18 ans il était invité pas drafté ring
invité aucun des périodes d'un zona try
out par rapport aux avocats des vaincus
domaine de camp des recrues se fait
inviter au gros qu'un ça va super bien
une jeune bretonne partout il donne
l'opportunité dernier était mort concots
viennent la voir
ga donne une grosse game qui tu fais
l'équipe bis et blablabla il est arrivé
une superbe hanging finale maillon
décida t jeunes on va donner une autre
année en juniors on congédie tout le
monde plus le même staff fut le même
monde plus ils veulent plus le même ciel
de joie ils recherchent plus pourquoi
lui avait invité l'a jamais réussi à
jouer l'hymne national était un match
hors-concours de jouer qui peut-être a
one carrière à jamais avoir mis patin
sur glace a pas vraiment sûr qu'on peut
et métiers sa chance c'est plate à dire
mais c'était quasi inaccessible mais
c'était celle-là puis a tout fait ce
qu'ils avaient à faire à 100% 5% de
chance idsud mauvais bord mais il ya
aussi un aspect de chance faut jamais
oublier quand quand tu parles de du
doute qui était probablement mieux placé
que la grande majorité des gens pour en
parler mais j'ai l'impression que quatre
temps québécois ou catherine un portier
en fait qui joue à montréal
tout est accentué fois mille c'est le
doute admet donc toi même à l'intérieur
le ta tête tu m'as dire crise on dirait
que le jeu commence à je commence à être
plus frileux dalida lembach pour pour
l'époque d'un coin puis que l'attentât
c'est vous dire si c'est du 24 heures
quasiment au québec locke et le tout les
temps que cholet il ya un tokyo à chaque
plage horaire du nord pendant 24 heures
pratiquement puis chaque tokyo vont
accentuer la nouvelle un petit peu comme
un jeu de téléphone ou est-ce que c'est
comme la tendresse sur ce je l'aï ai
parlé d un coin plus l'autre d'après ca
et la tendresse hygro mai
et il ya par ailleurs peu après sur le
tout se lève le matin puis puisque tout
dans le journal de montréal s'est tu
sais je suis fait que ça va peut-être
encore pire
je veux dire mais le plus dur le plus
dur c'est d'être des mal perçu ceci je
parle pour moi la petit j'ai commencé
mon premier cas j'ai frappé et je me
suis aucun d'évacuer cette aventure
honnêtement c'est juste parler du côté
chances dans ce tournoi là j'ai je pense
j'ai trop gros qui ont fait une pause
puis se sont vidés directement sous
genre frank moore ben pareil si je
prends jean louis ibres 2 ou 3 go ainsi
hier à l'hôpital genre sur une mise en
échec ça c'est quand ça marche je t'ai
vu aucun montréal ç'a super bien été ma
première game hors concours
c'est sûr c'est quelque chose que je
regarde beaucoup même mise en échec je
termine la carrière de globe des
maillots c'est mon premier shift ma
première game hors concours contre
impôts j'embarque sur la glace traverse
la glace j'ai le goût et le toucher sa
glace carrière terminée du match c'est
que ce sacré genre kiss cool star
baigneurs qui s'étend un but quatre plus
tard ghost hunters fait ça c'est moi je
t'ai eu d'envié gayet grosses basses par
5-0 maternal t-il 000 hl dans la vie je
traduis pas quelqu'un qui m'a chicane et
je m'en allais cc comme je suis vraiment
pas comme ça je suis vraiment la
question et c'est vraiment pas mon
identité
j'ai jamais été junior oui je finissais
mes mises en échec mais jamais dans
l'intention de blesser ou j'étais un
gosse un score de but et j'ai eu à 18
ans je kiffe 43 but en cinq matchs no 6
ça c'est moi ces jo en avantage
numérique c'est d'être benyoub frappé
tout le monde sait aucune date à aarau -
accès a été perçue comme un gars qu'il
fallait il fallait qu'ils banques
grecques qui 0 ma personnalité de l'aube
entre deux marques débuts en ayant
peut-être bon de temps de glace que
prévu ou pour ma pensée ça pour te faire
shine et puis pythie gdg du globe à
prendre la balle certains soirs que je
n'ai eu l'opportunité que j'aurai plus
de meilleurs que j'ai pas saisi en a
d'autres que je les saisies qui
s'approfondit t je me souviens début
d'année avec alex tanguay saku koivu je
pense à 17 points 11 matches s'est gelé
saisi ma chance je l' ai montré que
j'étais capable
avec un chris higgins est revenu de sa
blessure mais il menace puis ce qui est
correct ce n'est ni l'archipel moi je
respecte ce jeudi il ya des fois je n'ai
peut-être pas pris assez mais il ya des
fois que je les prie que ça pas
fonctionné peut-être puis quand j'allais
minnesota celle de l'éclosion on me
donnait la chance vraiment de la forêt
mon éclosion de c est ce qu est ce que
tu penses que malgré des charges et
entendait parler je pas si je pense que
c'était dans l'enclavé entendait des
articles du regretté rieth avait été
heureux de jours pour montréal mais
penses tu que c'est avait été drafté
ailleurs ou est ce qu'il n'ya pas la
pression constante des médias ou est ce
qu'il n'ya pas tout le temps mais comme
tu parlais je pense qu'il ya une
sauteuse tête le monde d'idées s'allumer
personne te tient compte de ce que tu as
game diab soir le tic est ce que tu
penses que tu aurais eu un développement
différent ce que j'aurais probablement
est-ce que j'aurais peut-être pas eu
aussi si j'ai eu un appui exceptionnel
le mois du jeu 19 l'autre et ça marche
bien mais les fans c'est en arrière puis
à une pression aussi médiatique énorme
qui m'ont probablement aider même si je
pense que j'ai fait ma chance dans ce
sens que j'ai eu un gros qu'un 18
je suis revenu au 19 juin 46 bon c'est
ça c'est une des enfants et je suis plus
fier de ma carrière c'est les la qualité
de mes cannes environnement la
préparation que je faisais mais est ce
que ça aurait été différent
probablement probablement mais ce que
changer de quoi puis je garde la même
réponse change de riz peut-être même que
riche tu sais j'aurais aimé ça moi et ma
carrière de dix ans 12 ans 15 ans à
montréal jusqu'à s'est porté le choix
des canadiens s'arrêter sur ma carrière
ma fierté si je l'avais fait
si autant que max lapierre et certains
ont dit que je comprends pourquoi ils se
veulent eux d'échangés de 2 jusqu'à 4
août
il coûte pochoirs et pillé
bleu-blanc-rouge tatoué que c'est un
malade comme eddy gones même qui tu fais
ton identique qui est ton image de
marque que je comprends qu'ils aient
qu'ils voient pas plus loin que h&m -
son style de jeu maintenant si je pense
que web ces échanges et aussi pour r
les esprits qui ait changé pour des
affaires qui se concrétiseront
probablement jamais pratique s'est
montrée d'amour dans un sens c'est pour
moi c'est un honneur dans un sens
j'étais genre est un gros trail camargue
est échangé contre price andrei sortie
quatrième n'y a pas eu le début de
carrière qui vous voulez mais c'est un
beau pour moi c'est un beau guimbeau des
deux équipes les deux équipes parce que
du côté du lycée de foix moi je pense
que leur potentiel mais y'a pas été
maximisée puis global de donner des
opportunités
puis c'est ce qu il manque de maturité
en ce moment elle peut-être kibora
premier d'un prochaines années que ça va
donner le but de mon espérer avec des
deux bords c'est je pense pas qu'on
était des images de mares de france pour
intégrer des footeux tour je pense pas
qu'on ait changé problème pourquoi blind
ans jusque ont échangé de legault qui
était perdue qui le mental tpu lequel il
cherche et cherche à sortir la tête de
l'eau ils n'y arrivaient pas le faire
mais dès qu'elle arrive elle file est à
l'intérieur
[Musique]
ouais c'est ça ben pouliot taux
nettement même si on le dit mais un jour
j'ai vu jouer la normale s'esquisse
spitz ice le tour boxe c'est malade
gueule jouer les télés dominé le mans
j'ai vraiment fait ce gala mais jamais
réussi à aller chercher le petit edge
207 cc ça m'amène à parler de ce draft
le la france était dans l'année de jeff
puis moi chaque fois que je regarde si
je m'abuse des fois attaqué les doivent
pouvoir qui avait été drafté à 20
quitter maintenant tout en perspective
puis ce draft là c'est un des meilleurs
du raf des 20 dernières années est
évidemment tolède liner qui soutenait
crosby qui sort en premier avec toute la
lotto crosby qui est elle bel des blues
que ça parce que c'était poste local
fait que ce n'était pas jean rey s'était
pas l'ordre normal
non c'était pas une grosse sono exact
exact c'est ce qui est
mais c'est un job je veux dire sur garde
puis ça descend bolou escrime d'un
cinquième ronde des gars qui font des
acheteurs encore le site avait c'était
vraiment un grave qui est l aude et
comment tu l'as tu vécu ce que matt est
arrivé en rentrant dedans parce que tout
avait beaucoup de rumeurs de premier
tour un peu brisé par des blessures par
une blessure en fin de saison
bref c'est clair si le deuxième belge
déclare aussi m au top 10 à 17 ans à 16
ans après mon année de la dette road
again je me suis pété l'épaule comme val
d'orge et et six mois août
actuellement je me suis cassé
l'enveloppent aussi une grosse opération
ça m'a fait manquer six mois quand je
suis venu j'avais pas le petit edge que
j'avais peut-être à 16 ans ça a été l'un
des 17 ans dont je suis à réparer mais
qui a été plus dur que je m'attendais
qui a fait en sorte que j'ai juste
gilles acculé dans le drame vécu les
deux parties cop10 donc 25 finalement
dernière liste de 59 sur canal
mais si je suis canadien m'avait sur
leur liste beaucoup bonne avance mais il
risque sera pas les charges là c'est
c'est vraiment un bon repêchage dans le
sens que c'est vraiment diversifié dans
la qualité de leurs rangs un joueur si
tu regarde si carey price est cinquième
à montréal c'est à dire go s'est imposé
comme étant discret en dehors je pense
indiqué peter je pense ils doivent situe
d'abord d'orly plus jeune que moi meetic
fois élu le bourdon qui est décidé
aujourd'hui que j'embrasse là où le mais
c'est un joueur exceptionnel du dit que
le jack johnson a eu un être unique eux
qui ont eu des carrières le d'éthique
on commence à 19 ans à 18 ans comme ceux
qui ont encore en ce moment les
carrières est encore notre les meilleurs
de la ligue
ça sent le coup et je pense qu'ils
sortie aussi c'était à ses étudiants et
ndèye diodio s'il a néanmoins pas
tellement si brooke shields a aussi
blanchi l'année gets place de
5 les annonces et 2000 et 2003 ces deux
ans puisque mathieu vraiment les joueurs
intéressants mais dix joueurs autant de
ses marques et doivent les excès stade
rafle c'est à des gars vraiment de
qualité qui ont sorti puis pour juste
d'un disque vraiment vraiment beaux
draps le funds
quand quand tu vois toutes ces galères
qui sont encore dans le show qui ont été
vraiment moins limités par les blessures
que toi qu'est-ce que qu'est ce que ça
te fait tout penses tu que tu parlais de
chance tantôt les blessures c'est un
gros facteur chance d'un gros facteur
malchance en fait qu'est ce que tu
penses que aurait été là la possibilité
détendu de ta carrière sans les
blessures ça les commotions ça je pense
que je suis encore capable jouer mais
elle est vraiment fallu que je fasse un
virage 2 360 par rapport à ma façon de
ces mots je prends le cas mais se jouer
bien besoin c'est plus la réalité
d'aujourd'hui
elle pourrait être capable de jouer dans
la ligue il a fallu que je baille ce mot
c'est moi jamais ce jour d'autres 2,25
deux études il y avait fallu je descends
dans votre 200 probablement pour jouer
dans alors qu'ils d'aujourd'hui la
vitesse de ces facs avait été son plus
gros challenge parce que tu t'es pas un
but qui avait une technique de patin qui
était la meilleure au monde peu importe
que ce que j'aurais fait au niveau pro y
avait toujours cette incapacité la aller
chercher leurs huit shows complets aller
chercher vraiment la latitude de ne
pousse et de patins j'avais peut-être au
même si même si je pense que j'étais
classé plus là je me voyais il aurait
fallu façon autonome là dessus par
rapport à un pc mon tour pour rentrer
d'un nouveau scandale national
c'est de la vitesse et des lego sont
jeunes s'entraînent depuis longtemps
c'est des machines seront protéines et
sont tous nos témoins jamais pris un
supplément et jamais personne na li
l'attisé quand même
jacques séguéla c'est vraiment la
réalité a complètement changé qui énonce
que le portugais ouais c'est ce refus de
la violence et sur d'autres prenaient de
dimensionner qui sont contre ce qui avec
le changement de style de justement plus
rapides les plus légers est-ce que
l'espoir est moins dangereuse oui tous
dangereux qui était il le sport peut
importe la grosseur va toujours rester
dangereux parce que si je prends juste
un exemple ces commotions un gode 200
livres qui rentrent à 35km à bien un but
200 livres qui rentrent à 35 km à la
force d'un pack est tellement énorme
c'est un épaule avec la projection sur
un d'un petit cran s'est fait la force
d'impact sur un crâne peu importe le
poète est ce qu'on veut la force de
propulsion et 23 hommes parce qu'on s'en
vont dans des sens opposés
peu importe l'endroit des joueurs peu
importe ce qu'on va faire
peu importe les casques ont représenté
un coût des pôles seulement ton ou un
coût des pauses dans le geste que je
tombe puis le web flash ça va toujours
rester une blessure une commotion c'est
certain parce qu'ils sont trop vite
trouvaille les godasses et mussy muscles
et même ceux des épaules de feu de ces
maladies
il n'est pas comme on dit at on su qu'il
ne puisse inciter à vis des
recommandations afin ou des
modifications à apporter à comment que
le jeu et jouer ou pas manqué pour que
ce problème là parce que ce n'est pas un
problème je pense de création des
blessures au hockey pour cesson -
problème qu'est ce qu'est ce qu'est ce
qu'on pouvait c'est drôle à dire parce
que ma carrière est arrêté que les
crémations puis les problèmes d'atteinte
petits enfants à l'eau puisque je suis
un de ceux qui font alors qu'ils
physique sur un seul pour les bagarres
parce que ça fait partie du hockey
nord-américain des bagages des jeans
d'offres qui sont plus enlevés je pense
que ça fait partie mais pas encore pour
garder le respect pour garder quelqu'un
sur qui si je fais ça je le sais que
j'aime pas
dis que tu vas y penser deux fois avant
de faire mais si tu le fais tout d'abord
une répercussion après je veux que ça
change d'avis et mentalement surtout
dans une société nord-américaine qui a
été éduquée qui a été levée et je pense
que le le plus gros conseil que je
pourrais dire c'est au québec au québec
quand on donne des cours de mise en
échec qui on donne des piges je sais
qu'ils font bien là j'en ai suivi des
cours pour les coaches font une bonne
job mais ces deux d'optimiser le message
aux entraîneurs que autres agresseurs
vont comprendre qu'ils vont emmener aux
joueurs le but d'une mise en échec dans
leurs eaux qui s'est pas de blesser le
joueur adverse
c'est pas de rentrer dans 5e ranger en
haut le but d'une mise en échec c'est de
frapper au panier de couper son
ascension vers la zone offensive et de
récupérer la rondelle en aucun temps
parce que je viens d'y eu un contact
physique corps à corps ce qu'on parle
plus le temps et l'espace du joueur pour
prendre possession de la rondelle
c'est une vraie mise en échec donc je
pense que c'est le message du départ
qu'on doit apprendre qu'on doit emmener
aux entraîneurs qu'on doit mener ou joie
parce que c'est là que ça oui une grosse
mise en échec ça change la guigne ça
change même espace où le besoin
ce que tu as besoin d'une récupération
de rondelles c'est une récupération des
actifs qui prête puisque justement lui
de montrer tes gars faune et des mises
en échec une employée est en 5e rang
j'ai fait montre a créé un revirement
qui est un loose patrick super état
qu'on est parti on est reparti aux morts
[ __ ] mais dedans je me dis que si je
te bulot avoir pas mal plus mal que la
mise en échec d'année donc on devrait se
concentrer peut-être sur d'autres choses
autre que juste la grosse mise en échec
qui change le change de ton le sens
vraiment changé le ton misant taylor qui
dinosaures on n'est plus la date je
pense que c'est dans l'éducation de nos
jeunes qu'on doit
j'ai vraiment l'impression peas et c'est
super intéressant ce que tu dis là parce
que encore une fois corrigez moi si je
me trompe
j'ai l'impression que quoi qu'il ya
vraiment une culture de tough on voit
mettant dans le vent une coupe d'années
avait il ya un montage qui circulait sur
internet vous l'avez sûrement vu ça à
était virale c'était deux clips
c'était un clip à gauche c'est alexander
ovechkin qui est debout ça debout sur le
banc puis une porte qui rentrent à
pleine vitesse dans sa gueule il fait
juste claque puis sortons de vente
il continue à checker s'espacent à glace
bien côté c'était une game de soccer ou
est-ce qu'un gars qui se fait pas touché
puis lecteurs matters tourner qui spawn
la junte
il ya vraiment une culture de comme si
tu mets une visière si tu veux pas d'un
coin si je gèle pas légaux quant à
l'occasion des gelées vingt et un
possibles
et puis à risque de parler compte des
gens de gens sensés tantôt spitting
chiclet s'ils font un petit peu châtié
bisnas ch'ti et ayant un petit peu cette
mentalité là dessus porte une vision
certes eu d'écho l'historien pour moi
puis pitt est pas un tough billet ce
genre de discours logique et moi je
trouve extrêmement intéressant
extrêmement pertinent de dire la mise en
échec ce soir a donné un avantage
stratégique à l'intérieur du jeu j'ai
l'impression que c'est pas tout le monde
qui partagent cette idée loeb sait pas
tout le monde qui véhiculent ces dans
ses idéaux lieutenant justin gros fléau
de la game encore quand mais bon ma
glace plus grands
pourquoi dit on veut trouver une façon
que ce système fait mal à quelqu'un
c'est pas compliqué il faut partir des
jeunes faut inculquer une nouvelle
philosophie nouvelle édition de la
guigne aux jeunes dans la aux 7-12 ans
pour que quand ils m'ont la game le mans
la façon de la jouer différente si oui
combien de fois sur ce qu'est ce que tu
fais comme tu dis que je suis encore un
francophone avec save your mother
c'est quoi le jour on va se voir un
terrain de golf à marrakech tout et
marque un deuil pour être
automatiquement
c'est moi j'ai jamais eu j'aime mieux
faire attention ajustements cdc
d'essence primaires qui sont tellement
importants que je trouve ça tellement
macho est complètement stupide de
d'avoir des messages de même des
mosquées son propos c'est que l'homme
armé tente ici je prends l'exemple de
business it is that is gold a fait sa
carrière là-dessus
j'espère lui est bâti sur la philosophie
des violences de fort mal de dépit c'est
correct comme je te dis je suis pas là
pour juger personne à leur évaluation de
la ging ou comment devrait jouer seule
chose c'est qu'ils ont de repousses
protéger faut que les gars commencent à
comprendre les réalités de la prée parce
que quand tu es dans la game
ces mots là si j'avais pu la relation
monnex jamais les prodiges comme lui mon
cas je serais probablement encore en
train de jouer et je ferai sûrement de
l'alzheimer et 38 ans mais c'est en
réalité parce qu'on est là dedans on est
en ddr frère qui veulent personne on est
des machines de performance on n'est pas
capable de gens à arrêter de jouer le
secteur 3-4 jobs en même temps parce que
c'est de la performance ou réussi à
aller chercher cette adrénaline leur
faut réussir à les uns maximiser quelque
chose à qui j'ai un bac dans ce projet
logement vol c'est ça on est habitué à
force c'est notre vie on est depuis
qu'on est jeune qu'on n'est pas bons
bâtir là dessus ça qu'il ya vraiment une
philosophie une culture une vision du
sport professionnel comme doit trouver
une façon de protéger nos jeunes qui
s'en viennent là dedans puis si on parle
de cela maintenant on parle au québec
c'est un bonheur pour cent le qui vont
jouer en national ces factions punchy
protéger nos jeunes on peut cependant
l'attention leur taille aux cayes et
rendu m pour lui les commotions sont
inactifs puis qui avait point de
s'arrêter tout capable d'être 5e tour
maladie qui compte 2 2 on peut tu pensé
aux vraies affaires on a besoin on est
capable de donner la chance à toutes les
jeunes de performer en se protégeant
bien changé de philosophie pour rendre
le sport propre et plus beau moi je suis
ça s'enlever la vie sans lever des mises
en échec sont d'aimer les rendent moins
dangereuses les rendre plus intelligent
moi c'est assez versatile
au niveau des bagarres six mois
maintenant justement d'un homme naïf
connais pas je le voyais donc on wheels
ans qui a encore des batailles dans des
sports comme ce tea party méthodes de
ghost apprécié la gueule la sortie d'un
bar la nuit jeudi soir marqués baisse
une glace pourquoi c'était le ricain qui
n'en parle pas dans le sport comme la
boxe ou si seul jeudi le sauf que quand
l'heure ce genre de laraque au parc
ajustements il ya a mené comme une autre
vision à que j'avais jamais pensé qu'
aucun qui ait des bagarres ou caen qui
est ici que la possibilité à bagan
existe c'est comme s'il y avait un
respect supplémentaires puis avec il ne
faisait plus attention il y avait moins
de coups je découpe au moins une course
et je peux voir georges laraque qui
arrive artois avec ces gars à glace
bataille de suippes ans deux fois mais
de jouer avec georges ouais j'ai joué
jazz puis j'ai une histoire qui donne à
monsieur sidi cheikh d'ajman
je me suis penché avec les oies qui ont
100 brown qui loge fini une mise en
échec mais solide
c'est vraiment dingue les gosses à lille
un bon feeling de jantes en arrière
tender away monte à bernay frappe rapide
même à wave y étant ici l'écho après
parle à peu près le même si j'ai pas
fais pipi dans ma culotte
c'était mouillé mais ces appareils est
le prochain coup j'aurais donné ma mise
en échec puis je vais avoir le logo
jouant le jeu cela donnait morning sais
si je m'en venais je lève le coude du
jeu et je sais que je ne comprends pas
que c'est moi c'est dans cet aspect là
que je trouve que c'est d'avoir dit
georges fidèles blogueurs sont faits
soft sauvegarde qui dope les gars qui se
battent pour être le plus fort le roi de
la montagne ce chemin pour ça les gardes
et les bagarres pour y implanter un
respect ça bâtiment
je suis en trouve que salir encore sa
place dans l'heure qui noir américain
justin bieber qui a des problèmes de
taille qui vivent de ce qu elle encore
qui parle qui dit cela si l'on sache que
je véhicule c'est pas la violence celle
inverse
mais je pense qu'il ya trop de go qui
profiteraient de la situation qui aurait
pu être beaucoup plus grave que ce que
je devais vraiment ce que ça te répète
le rôle de dédé arbitres justement de
s'assurer qu'ils haïssent le respect le
pillage thomas qui avait pas de coups
bas de coucher plus tôt ça soit comme la
loi bosman la france et ça ça va vite
l'apprendre est plus d'arbitrés non
méritée moi je pense que peut-être on va
l'emmener au fait qu'il ya quatre à vis
de sa glace public comme on en voit deux
autres écoles
peut-être que ça va venir à saint geours
mais il reste il reste que la beauté ce
sport là c'est de trouver la façon peu
importe laquelle le battre à dire ça si
c'est si la beauté de ce slogan que
football le football c'est la même chose
c'est dans quelles faiblesses que je
peux atteindre mon adversaire
les autres sais pas qui c'est pas en
bagarre c'est pas aux autres c'est
vraiment la stratégie dans l'étude de
l'adversaire jo c'est vraiment plus dans
dans l'instinct d'en connaître les
tendances d'en connaître le grand de
leur savoir faire dans des vidéos des
sciences et aux deux tiers qui est
passée de juin c'est comme dire quand
bob gainey avait congédié carpeaux
mitterrand a triplé la première fois que
vous avez dire promet ging prenez un
game nautile avec toutes les notes des
joueurs
apprenez s'équilibre l'aube à saclay
soirée l'atelier en arriver là disait
bon et parfait s'attendrait à ce qu'il
joue la défense au bord bon c'est ph
quand un défenseur gaucher 8 buts 13
passes parfaites eu six mois conclut
bailly gauche et ça veut dire que tu
protèges taraude et il y avait vraiment
un étude lagging beaucoup plus loin que
ce qu'on est habitué dans l'heure qui
j'avais trouvé ça super intéressant que
je pense que blanc qui doit développer
des façons de je trouve qu'on est
stupide dans notre sport trop court ni
stupide que l'année passée j'ai eu la
chance d'aller à 15,6 libye j'ai
vraiment à gérer avec l'a1 qui on a vu
cette conversation sur mon mouton livre
de jeu j'écoutais tabarnak si nagui post
it et dans ses cellules exact puisque
comme jeu
c'est sûr que c'est dur à faire parce
que nous aussi c'est de l'instinct situe
au dessus 5 secondes ça cif encore sur
place en une formation donc la réalité
est pas la même mais je trouve qu on est
situé dans le sens que l'on monte trois
filles sauf robert qu'on aimait les six
pas normal ou normal qu'on se focalise
de faire deux ou trois cl d'échec avant
ce pas normal c'est par ce pour quoi on
se concentre pas si bonnes choses au
lieu de montrer des jeunes dans le pee
wee à forte chez kia de 1,2 le voici à
deux pour chaque nom c'est quoi le rôle
du premier
c'est quoi les options du premier parfum
une fois que le premier on a atteint
l'objectif
on va rentrer le deuxième pour dire si
je porte chèque à 2 c koi l'intention
des joueurs ça fat man s'est
complètement ce qu'il faut changer pour
changer de type servian ce que je disais
tantôt notre approche des joueurs doit
changer on doit montrer la guînes
on doit arrêter de jouer la game au dos
l'a montré et donner les raisons les
jeunes à ce travail savoir le pourquoi
du faut leur donner ces réponses
c'est important les joueurs en défensive
le premier défenseur keith harmon en
quoi freiner sa mise en sc quoi
l'intention derrière son moule peu
importe le système de jeu que je joue
dans la vie c'est quoi l'intention de
gaulle à en affiner son nous c'est usant
des lieux vers le haut
si tu perds tu coupes et l'espace pour
l'emmener dans l'entonnoir vers le coin
son bord dont deux positionnés ou
pourquoi s'emboîtent repositionner c'est
ce qu'il faut emmener ou joueurs à
comprendre le rôle de chaque individu
dans chaque situation sympathie non pour
faire en sorte que je me donne espoir je
m'en vais jouer mais je trouve pas le
même système mais je comprends tout cela
positionnement des joueurs j'ai compris
le rôle de chaque doigt
c'est vraiment une approche faut avoir
un nouvel avis que c'est ma façon
d'avoir c'est ce que je vais essayer
d'amener ici à achard le monde sait ce
que je trouve ça je trouve ça vraiment
pertinent de la différence entre
demander aux jeunes de faire quelque
chose puis lui expliquer pourquoi se
doter de fait je vais prendre un autre
exemple moi et j'ai mangé pendant
pendant plus de vingt ans puis en ayant
un switch dans ma carrière de nageur ou
est-ce que
j'étais tanné de juste faire
l'entraînement par ce qui m'était
demandé d'être fait sans avoir la
justification de pourquoi y était il
devait être fait parce que le jeu cancer
elle dit que qui est crise nous sommes
piégés ont fait certaines affaires qui
pour moi font pas de sens fait ma
motivation de les faire diminuer
grandement parce que je comprenais pas
pourquoi on les faisait alors qu'ils en
aient quand j'ai demandé à mon
entraîneur je dis lui ça me prendrait la
justification de pourquoi on fait sur
pourquoi est ce qu'est aujourd'hui cet
entraînement le est nécessaire pourquoi
est ce que demain ça va être celui là
puis quand j'ai commencé à voir les
explications au début ça a été difficile
d'en avoir parce que c'est ce que j'ai
réalisé y en avait pas vraiment puis
quand finalement j'ai changé de deux
groupes d'entraînement que son
entraîneur que le général isik acquis
non ça se peut d'avoir une justification
puis un plan à long terme qu'une
explication de pourquoi je fais ce
prix-là minutes que j'ai commencé à voir
ce j'étais vraiment plus motivés de
m'entraîner je n'ai vraiment plus
motivés de le faire j'ai l'impression
que plus largement pour les gens qui
nous écoutent kiwi light peut-être un
peu moins ou au sport c'est la même
chose dans n'importe quoi tu travaille
pour une entreprise c'est une tâche à
faire tu veux compte explique pourquoi
la tâche est important ici tu réalises
pourquoi est importante
ben tu vas voir deux fois plus envie de
la fin du show je trouve qu'on a perdu
tout l'aspect d'atteinte d'objectifs
signé je le mets dans le sport ou dans
n'importe quelle entreprise
si je prends le ton lors qu'ils facile
pour moi on sent voleurs qui ont
journaux dits niveau de jeunes pee wee
ses premières années des deux secondes
amateurs mais on sent vaud qui ont leur
monde des affaires de seconde à st parce
qu'on pense aux résultats puis on pense
à garmin ont fixé des objectifs pourquoi
quand combat l'école là on apprend le
mandarin ou ma fille en ce moment est en
première année à la barre ali
d'après un petit peu a compté à lasser
de trouver des terrains
pourquoi elle a fait ça pourquoi ils pas
des gens n'aiment pas ce qui est pas
capable la fois mais c'est ce qu'ont
fait le problème qui sait qu'on se
concentre sur le résultat on se
concentre sur ajoute les
jusque là manque d'amour à jour mon
accueil petit il a été retiré bonne
échec-avant qui sont pas au repli est
vraiment solide
voyons se développe koala développent
aucun joueur audois qui comprend dont
ckoi bosse tous des objectifs
secondaires la même enfant à l'école
secondaire j'ai des objectifs 2010
objectif j'en ai trois parcelles par
trimestre on est trop top
j'en ai un j'en ai deux parfaits jeu
bordeaux se bat c'est parfait je finis
mon année 1 j'ai atteint mes objectifs
de ce que je voulais pas tout le monde
dans les arènes au même niveau mais au
moins on va avoir une base chaque joueur
dans certaines d'objectifs je m'en veux
à présent en deuxième secondaire parfait
ça même à faro au quai et les objectifs
que j'ai atteint l'année passée je fais
un week-end ou en début de saison
donc mon premier moi c'est oui car on
risque de près ce qui est long on évolue
on se rende en secondaire sein de la
même façon qu'à l'école où je tournais
atteint les objectifs
année après année au savon après si je
te dis c'est fou le savoy patiner ça va
se positionner savoir et faire une
récupération de rim servant savoir
prendre une pause bac mcd attitude qu'on
a pas rendu bantam mais dieu ce qui est
insensible
c'est un salarié d'avoir un lieu et qui
se place au spot d'ovechkin si ya pas de
26 parades à faire un one time c'est un
autre enfant avec un jouet roi des
pratiques mongongu pee wee b - illégaux
sont là ils font des vins timer font 10
l'action qu'elles sont mais pas à faire
une pelouse balayée
je pense qu'on votait pour moi je dis ça
en fait un exercice qui a trois passes
il ya deux pas de manquer la tue mon
sens vos pratiques et c'est je pense
qu'il faut comprendre on veut aller trop
vite dans tout il faut prendre le temps
de faire les choses comme il faut pour
le développement de l'athlète la
développement de la personne 70 parties
de autant l'importance de prendre le
temps danse autant prendre le temps d'en
expliquer c'est quoi la nutrition
expliqué la psychologie sportive et qui
sait quoi
qu'est ce que tu vois vivre par son
cerveau plus gros mois de l'année un
pays où ils pillent oui 3.8 québec en
plus de savoir une personne ressource
qui menait les leurs expliqué c'est quoi
la pression qu'est-ce qu'ils vont
ressentir c'est quoi ils fourmis dans
les jambes n'ont jamais vxo ont pu leur
offrir un suspense pour les jeunes de 11
ans
à lui est choqué lui par des post it
shows que komatsu peu des seuls qui
avaient été mis dans une situation que
jamais les voir dans quel monde tu dis
c'est parce qu'on est vraiment une
restructuration dans toute l'histoire de
la game dans toutes les formes en talons
nice offre est ce qu'il faut revoir pour
vraiment amélioré notre programme rock
et puis je jette pas le blanc sur
personne je suis pas en train de dire
quand et québec open job c'est pas
facile ce qu'ils font on a beaucoup de
secteurs de beaucoup de régions de
beaucoup de personnes qui qui est qui
moi je pense qu'on prend pas assez
d'aller deux ans prend pas c'est d'être
d'anciens otages d'un exemple comme une
folle dit carbonneau a dit un mot sur
québec m'appelait pour aider donner un
choix ou un équipement club ce n'est des
mois ce que cherche je veux carbo sur
mappy ya poursuit d'appel le 10 en un
mois ce qui vient de donner son point de
vue on se protège on fait attention à
nos fins que je pense qu'on a vraiment
quelque chose à regarder même si comme
je dis le penser plus loin que justin
bieber qui s'en sort parce que les
rebelles qu'on parlait plutôt charmant
désocialisation trop tout ce que tu dis
je reconnais aussi mettons en natation
le spock et mon père on a fait très tôt
un jeune lillois 11 12 ans puis
rapidement ses enfants qui lui il
enregistre lui une hausse du taux du
nord jabra sinon tel style ti rapidement
l'histoire de longues distances à une
époque et encore à peaufiner développer
tout peut changer ici rapidement tourner
à ta carrière de sportif tu dis à moi
j'veux pas bon la barre mojtaba tout
moment à brasse juste un jeu innocent ce
risque de diderot jamais de rock viendra
jamais bon à la chose que que tu étais
convaincu toi même que tu étais pas bon
takis ce we à manille peut-être qu'à 18
20 et 22 ans l'eau effectivement de
l'autre vont retrouver une spécialité
parce que mes sauf que peu avancé je
commençais fait donc dans plusieurs
sports au sein même de transport avant
dirty cité se catégoriser pas toucher à
toutes les religions c'est çà mau sauf
si ça vient je suppose cependant leur
qu'il positionnement
l'ailier gauche qu'elle jamais joué en
défense comme une fois de son entente
j'ai donné à défendre jbeil pas bon un
voisin défendre soir quand le pack ali
depuis que le job en face vas-y wakfs
prend la choque parce que six paniers
pas les savants échapper jambes à voir
comment de ce mariage est ici c'est à la
défense j'ai faites m'ont dit tu dis
j'ai donné leurs savantes il échapper y
pas beau à voir et mes visites
positionner bien que la gueule ça fait
trois ans qu'ils patinent et ça se peut
que tu en fasses ainsi qu'au coût
d'environ 3 avec métier mais c'est sur
faut comprendre comment les jeunes dans
une situation qu'il faut qu'ils
comprennent la réalité des eaux qui sont
en les mettant dans des positions qui
vont vivre le stress qui vont vite que
les autres qui vont si je mets un
attaquant comme défenseur ben tu te dis
pas pour une saison complète mais ça
change quand il ya le game 2 juste pour
voir a dit lui seul sait ce qu'il veut
si lui tourne dans le centre son timing
n'est pas bon il peut pas me la donnez
le pack quand même aux jeunes woippy le
pti c'est important ça c'est la notion
du porteur non par transporteur a trouvé
le mont portant ce nom porteur à se
dégager pour que le porteur le trou une
nuance qu'on oublie là il m'a pas vu
jeter l'eau loin et est l homme et lui
sa vision est complètement différent
mais c'est que je souhaitais jeunes du
sua sauce qui voit c'est quoi la vraie
ging c'est quoi les options d autres
partenaires sa glace a mentionné
certains n'ont point que je trouve que
c'est tellement important puisque ça à
montgallet cet art est un joueur
ressente vraiment dans sa zone il coûte
à toi il peint positionner ce qui est
tout à la zone des lectures il protège
alors j'ai commencé à jouer
novice puis à la ma première saison de
hockey
maintenant qu'il soit ça me rappelle ça
ma première saison de hockey je n'avais
jamais joué au hockey
j'avais été pris comme une attaque 1
j'ai jamais remis
jamais été mis en défense de toute ma
vie 1 c'est comme à partir de à partir
de ma première saison alors que je t'ai
neuf ici j'étais un attaquant peut pas
nous sert moi moi qui vais décider le
mot j'avais dubaï je sais pas marquer
des but s'écoule du puits
je tairai salle avant pis ça me fait
penser à julian edelman le receveur de
passes des patriots de la nouvelle
angleterre que lui a joué tout son
collégiale comme quart arrière puis
quelqu'un il s'est fait recruter dans un
effet lié a appris qu'ils étaient
recrutés comme receveur de passes par
les pattes un poste distinct cops et
l'on parle on s'entend que c'est pas à
être un sens tout est un ailier gauche
n'annonçait pas l'arrière une piètre 1
recevront de passe passe que lui était
super athlétique il y avait des bonnes
mains puis connaissait toutes les routes
possibles lorsqu'ils étaient
quart-arrière fait qu'ils étaient
réputés on n'a pas besoin d'un quart
arrière mais on a besoin de recevoir
fait que tout va être recevable comme de
fait maintenant c'est un des meilleurs
de recevoir la ligne éthique ne sais pas
vous mais c'est ce que tu sais tu sais
qu est ce que le quart-arrière voies de
fait qui est précisément comme tu dis le
rapport aux défenseurs c'est qu'est-ce
que le quart-arrière voix fait tu sais
que quand un coverage qui est qui plus
loose tu sais que tu as besoin d'aller
le puits quand arrive à de bons patrons
sur le jet annonce et c'est super
intéressant plus que l'on regarde les
tendances où on regarde tout les sports
on regarde les sphères complètement
différent tu vois que les meilleurs ont
réussi à faire autre chose ont touché à
autre chose au tchad l'opposition
acceptait un appareil qui attire un
autre joueur élections il y en a des
joueurs qui sont vraiment sur ses sauts
pis si city comme moi maintenant je suis
zéro un jour 206 c'est un port tudy joua
défense avant jouer à au sens presque la
vie parce que premièrement la vitesse le
bouton gauche au ras le bol que ça fasse
croire à de gaulle a voce paris gratuité
s'est tous regardé ce canevas de gosses
qui font ensuite un peu ils vont aller
trouver la petite ligne acquise au titre
mais c'est ça que tu connaisses il a la
mentalité puisque le joueur fin mai mais
un boss et dans le pied en faisant du
bouche voici quand même assuré
c'est clair en ce moment' au dessus des
eaux quotidien du sud est d'aider des
problèmes suite à des commotions
m ouais j'ai encore j'ai encore banni
liban les problèmes des maux de tête
fatigue l'irritabilité
je compte j'ai réussi à contrôler un peu
mieux physiquement mon activité ma
gestion du stress
toutes ces choses le toutes les têtes
des symptômes quel monde on normale du
crashgate les bois on n'y touche pas mal
tangué celle du père du compas pas du
contrôle ou moins pris soin de moi
peut-être la dernière année d'un sens
que ça va être comme une dépression
n'était toujours un corps et après tu
écris moi je t'enlève comme justin tout
cas une cadence travail et qui sait sa
passion dans la vie parce que me des
roches dans la plaine de aussi j'ai
attaqué je me retrouve que c'est ce qu
un peu partout enfin que j'ai pas pris
soin de moi peut-être que je devais
faire une bonne alimentation au niveau
de la boisson de toutes ces choses de
savoir ce que je dis mais je dis juste
que je bouge à reprendre un peu le
contrôle là dessus pour prendre le
dessus sur celle des moules à ses
problèmes non je pense que c'est le sol
et ici ce que j'aime dit aux gens c'est
de comprendre la réalité d'aujourd'hui
le nouveau groupe ses membres est
atteint de la sclérose en plaques qui
est un peu la même chose c'est des
tâches au cerveau c'est ton cerveau qui
fonctionne moins bien c'est en ce qui
est de reloger tout ce qui est chimique
dans ton cerveau qui chez kiki brasse et
c'est quand je parle à ma main et décide
à ces symptômes comme un saint c'est un
peu la même réalité c'est oui j'ai pas
de risque de perdre les gens bougent
éthique on a l'air si je pensais
beaucoup plus graves la maladie qu'elle
peut avoir mais il reste il reste que
tout ce qui est au niveau de la fatigue
au niveau de la perte de mémoire au
niveau de ces choses ça se ressemble
beaucoup
puis vint coup jessop 6 un peu si un peu
le
moi c'est simple ce qui me fera partie
du magot queiroz à ma fille assise juste
32 juillet avec ceux qui imaginent
pendant dix ans si je rejoins de tous le
savoir est ce un peu un wii capcom au
jaï le sens que ok patel jouant près des
documents essayer de maximiser mon
talent pour prendre soin de ma personne
les effets à long terme des décorations
plus locomotion répéter c'est encore
assez méconnue on sait pas exactement
comment traiter ce mec toi mettons que
j'imagine que tu dois connaître ce tracé
nier ce sujet est ce que yo des
traitements est ce qu'il y ait quelque
chose que tu peux faire qu'est ce que tu
comptes chez moi j'ai tout fait je te
dirai l'élite est possible
et puis ça faisait partie l'egypte est
le manque d pas parce que je voulais
voir si une conférence là dessus puis
allez voir les impatients de disposer
dans l'espoir d entreprise de longueuil
tomasky biblique à travailler puis une
grosse firme ça même à fort william est
le même il n'y rien de son livre m en
fait je trouvais ça intéressant parce
que on pense souvent une commotion c'est
un coup à moi j'ai déjà dirigé l'équipe
que j'ai sorti mes matches que j'ai des
mises en échec qui sont même pas des
mêmes pas de mise en échec à la tête
c'est comme si ma façon de tomber c'est
faction csp quelque chose qui est bien
important pour moi d'essayer de
sensibiliser les gens sur la proche puis
le feeling de 41 commotion aussi les
symptômes que tu peux avoir mais aussi
des passants guérir moi j'ai essayé je
t'aime deux fois atlanta justin cela
porte à trois fois par jour en semaine
c'est la première fois que j'allais
faire ça a fonctionné un full la
troisième journée je me suis bien j'ai
dit j'ai 18 ans d'avoir un clip dans le
cerveau le jeu naissante il salue le feu
qui est allé à l'hôtel j'ai dormi 16
heures dessus
je testerai tout est correct pour la
deuxième fois que l'egypte ait le même
effet sa part marcher autant les tiges
et rend là-bas j'ai rencontré des gens
vis tu en avais jamais marché de sa vie
a fait le justin portman a fini la
semaine à la fête qingming impôt s'élève
à la fois qu'il doit on est là on a vu
la petite fille lundi avec nous au ainsi
le bout à cette neige est tellement un
peu capables marché est arrivé en
dernière journée parfaite distingue
cependant à face à martigues et par un
broc réel dans foot fifa que c'est une
technique qui a été utilisé que moi
j'essayais personnellement fonctionner
je pense que les commotions c'est
beaucoup aussi
ou ce que tu es rendu dans ton dans son
cheminement de récupération c'est super
important
je pense une question timing aussi une
question paraît même plus une question
de croyance à ce que tu t'en avoir comme
protocole si tu t'en vas dans un
appentis croix pour ton cerveau pourquoi
pas embarqué c'est moi je me suis lancé
la première fois orange et dit about je
l'essaie jboss je souris ma saison que
ça fonctionnait la deuxième fois je dois
le saluent cette voie sabotée acquiesça
l'autopsié c'est sûr que j'avais utilisé
le simple au centre de recherche martel
sur les traumatismes crâniens l'hôtel de
ville service choix de sang est un acte
fort juste debout j'ai toutefois
circuler le sang c'était une des
premières choses à poissons du chemin
inverse site web gauche propriété dans
le noir master 1 et randy quasiment
ailleurs dix ans pour tu bouges tue ou
juste face à laetitia roux dans une
limite à meilhan c'est important
qu'elles assument car même à guînes de
fin d'exercice physique ça va être
beaucoup mieux ça aussi c'est sur la
médiation
moi j'étais trop 2 1 2 3 1 sur le des
antidépresseurs comment va la douleur
pour changer le message que mon cerveau
envoyé le capex le message qu'envoie ce
n'est pas le bon et qu'on a ainsi de
changer mais je trouvais que ça a changé
ma personnel et je n'étais pas bien je
t'apporte à paul guillaume que jamais et
de la télé qui spontanée qui joyeux qui
échappait perdu
et là j'ai mieux vivre des problèmes de
commotion qu'a perds ma personnalité qui
fuit parce que déjà j'en ai perdu un bon
goût j'aimerais ça sourit ce qui me
reste deux personnalités la nouvelle
tendance ou six qui sont extrêmement
populaires que je t'avais d'essayer
aussi ça va l'une de ces bandes de potes
c'est ça la nouvelle promotion avec la
ligue nationale de danse part du lion
depuis que j'ai commencé un gain je suis
mieux là c'est ça a sauvé ma vie de sa
survie la vie littéralement fait ça
c'est dans les prochaines j'avais jamais
rencontré une compagnie de toronto
un des docteurs pour le dosage chez
chose de le plus souvent de la
collection mais c'est probablement le
prochain stable comme aux journalistes
c'est
plus en plus utilisé pour un million
d'affaires 1 million de ses bd c'est
qu'il ya pas le thc fait qu'ils aient
pas l'espèce de boss dans un an qui te
fait perdre la caf c'est vraiment
quelque chose qui est en écoute l'envoi
puis ça ça fait juste détendre
complètement puis on dirait que ça
personnellement mais c'est sûr que j'ai
pas eu de commotion cérébrale du moins
que je suis au courant puis j'ai pas ces
problèmes là que tu te décris mais moi
ce que ça fait c'est que permettant ya
vraiment beaucoup de choses qui tourne
dans ma tête quand je pense à 30 minutes
après béton le il ya une espèce de
silence dans mon cerveau pis ça fait
vraiment une puisque c'est vraiment un
article à l'endroit d'un sens que ces
génies john key avait des problèmes de
coûts qui ont commencé à prendre ce qui
le savoir-être épisode la nage de voir
des mouvements d'époque mais je suis
ensuite jamais été blessé mais en même
temps la natation mais l'assistance part
compense pas dur qui crée d'offres il
reste que c'est le sport le meilleur
sport tous sports confondus pour là
faudra l'autre pour la longévité ou la
forme physique
ici donc un impact est inquiète jonathan
gratis est malade c'est quand vous
laisse je me souviens quand je me suis
fait opérer 1800 coopération la même
journée j'ai eu deux hernies inguinales
sur les deux hommes qui m'ont opéré la
hanche
je la même journée la même journée cette
journée après journée puis les turinois
ils suspectent des maîtres artisans
n'est pas du vélo savent que le monde
subit mais je remercie sa coopération
2010 finalement c'est la technique on
avait ça dans l'eau je n'ai juste
jusqu'au bout et quand un peu de courant
juste un butin de seulement c'est parce
que j'aime et je guéris par berne
il souhaite opérer à 16 ans l'épaule
mais je fais bouger c'est vraiment boire
sa bouée moment où je serai 20 km de
vélo que ce marathon parviennent à
revenir dans le tour 2006 a longuement
réalise pas la lampe alors l'ampleur de
l'impact des blessures des yeux sur ces
maladies l'entrevue de martin brodeur
qui m a donné son accord qui pétillent
partout si ces malades le lego on est
des petits lui-même cartes et des petits
gilad dans des camps de dandy corps de
jeunes je pense peuvent performer comme
il faisait chaque site avait été
justement par les déclamations public te
disais que c'était pas de ta blonde
technique toujours encore people
notamment j'ai encore des commotions
subies
j'entends dire qu'elle podcast que tu
disais que tu es afin ward
le matin c'était quatre villes est
intéressante comme constamment est-ce
que ce qui malgré se met entre garde ta
carrière tu dis à qui une décision j'ai
pris je les assume pister les bonnes
décisions ou d'un torres mettons facture
est cultivé j'en étais déjà arrêté plus
tôt ben tu sais jamais ce sera la preuve
tu parles au docteur je peux pas
garantir que ces projets ne seront pas
légumes
je veux partager de garantie puis moi je
disais je me souviens parce que moi je
n'ai eu sa part aux apports de ce que
j'ai eue avant puis dans le junior
tonneins est que tu sais non non non je
n'ai eu qu'un cachet distinguent mais
dans mes trois dernières années
mariage en existe c'était commencer ma
deuxième année avec le wild
lochte avec mon ex qui je me souviens
pas ce que je dis c'est du mouvement
mais commotion semaine je suis six
semaines assis dans une chaise dans le
noir ici je vous adore marcher huit
minutes je dors 10 heures je vous dis
non non c'était vraiment agréable
je n'ai pas gagné ça je faisais et puis
après ça je me suis retrouvé que le 10
sport le je disais je suis comme une
fois gisenyi
je revenais au jeu lazio qui tu joues
asseoir sa dernière au et promis la
prochaine c'est fini que j'arrivais de
game après jordanienne au hockey on fait
lui à de celle là quand la pression par
là de la prochaine et dernière la
prochaine et on a fait ça c'est fois
c'est cette fois par septième fois et
ensuite je me suis jeté un suisse puis
m'ont dit gm avait dit et bas juba quand
un mort et ta famille pour payer nos
d'algérie denzel palais disponible
jusqu'au relaxant
puis moi je me disais j'avais dans ma
tête j'avais dans ma tête est toujours
donnée l'année
je vois aller après sahin en russie par
les cashes bien ce joueur je dois
arrêter de jouer
puis le genre par les pauvres gars de ce
blog
finalement quand on est allé mais on
n'est même pas en vacances un mois on
est amazigh a dit me suis littéralement
le power pourquoi au final de fac à 10
mois gammagraphie à le 6 mois asie je
m'en bat maison dit oui à l'industrie
alors si tu as les bosses tu le dis je
t'encourage je suis capable d'encourager
pas quelle décision qu'il voulait pas
obligé pas des jours en attendant votre
maison je peux plus être là à allier au
game qui tapait des mains qu'un cas pas
parce qu'après ce cil 1 c'est là que je
me suis assis green bay c'est quoi je
vous l'aï dit c'est quoi je veux dans la
vie c'est dessus c'est une belle qualité
de vie c'est tout d'avoir deux millions
de plus à mon compte devant ses études à
part de l'alzheimer est riche c'est cela
mon choix était à l'essai de quoi je
veux une qualité de vie je vais essayer
de trouver le maximum de ce que je
pourrais avoir qui tu vois même même l'a
d'ailleurs été je pense aux bons rails
mais je peux dire que certaines journées
que je n'échangerais pas de signes de
piasses pour villa qui est ce que je
pensais qu'on dit l'argent papa obama ou
peu importe il ya une réalité qui est
vrai en tabarouette égyptiens
moi j'étais le gars le plus choyé de
monde j'ai vécu mon bras est ce à dire s
est un parfait j'ai joué était là pour
se singulariser 340 g joug d'un player
de gaz moi j'ai vécu mon rêve
si je suis capable de vivre correctement
comme je le fais en ce moment le restant
de mes jours je pense que oui je viens
les problèmes
oui c'est pas parfait oui ce poteau mais
j'ai vécu mon rêve je suis a atteint un
objectif que je m'étais dit que j'ai
réussi à faire que ça dure et ça tant
mieux ça devrait s'arranger pas de sapin
plus de bonbons
qui aurait aimé cet amas place pour moi
j'ai aucune amertume par rapport à ma
carrière je suis juste efira est choyé
d'avoir dit tu seras c'est vraiment
dangereux c'est vraiment ma job
perçoivent c'est mon approche là tu te
fait quand même
[Musique]
ce n'est quand même des bons contrats
avec le wild du minnesota
est-ce que ça ça permet maintenant te
dire je vais faire ce que ce que j'aime
faire en vivant convenablement ou bien
est ce qu à ce moment là tu te fais
comme on entend souvent que les joueurs
ils vivent au dessus de leurs moyens par
une couple d'années ils ont une blessure
sa finition punition bah non je te
demande pas de dévoiler tonton est folle
j'espère qu'un pour la suite jusqu'à ma
vie maintenant si j'ai monté quatre
semaines mais non moi j'ai mon pass un
lieu qui est parti avec 0 qui s'est bâti
une entreprise aujourd'hui est vraiment
réussie d'un milieu de la construction
d'un milieu des finances dans le kit
passionné de finances qui lui a à 14 ans
sont pas les acheter des frigidaires
puis chercher une il a appris à la dure
puis en ayant mon frère que je véhicule
même rêve que moi qui a fait les mêmes
efforts que moi mais que moi je me
retrouvais avoir un million par année
avec le canadien lui faisait 60 milles
en europe ça te fait un petit chèque
parce qu'on ait fait le même parcours
même chemin je veux je me suis dit on
met deux fois je n'en avons pas
m'acheter une porsche ou est ok mais
parti pense à l'après dépenses autant
que ça va durer pense que ces étudiants
8 à 18 heures minuit attend deux aspects
si tu sais pas ce que ça va bien ça
finit à 26 moi j'ai toujours eu ce côté
là où j'avais dû bon nombre autour de
moi qui m'ont épaulé qui m'ont fait
comprendre les réalités que tu as juste
le goût de la loi pour shine america's
d'époque lugano fois que j'étais
chanceux la tue
et espère bien épaulé be aujourd'hui je
travaille par passion du travail parce
que j'aime ce que je fais et je suis
chanceux de leur structure
si je calcule le nombre d'heures que je
mets le salaire je suis bénévole c'est
moi je dis je fais c'est parce que
j'aime ce j'aime les jeunes veulent
transmettre ma passion mon amour des
jeunes je trouve qu'ils sont beaux sons
le fun et ont le goût de travailler les
uns chance vu aussi le rebord famille
énorme avec rds simon qui me donne des
contrôles ont donné contre 5,1 légitime
contre 3,6 malev tout ce qui se presse
du jour alors qu'il aura des contre
portes en jeu les plus jeunes ce que
j'espère pas mis le son le qui s'adapte
même à liboi ça se peut que je m'en
aille kochi pagadian on va juste et en
contrebas t&d ont le faut sur internet
aucun problème n 1 qui partira il lui
plaisait pas prêt on va traiter de ces
malades
c'est ce côté là je suis choyé à fond
d'avoir une avs en avait 2 - kim backs
trek ou deux chansons comme j'ai dit
j'ai réussi à protéger ce que j'ai j'ai
gagné
qui de leur côté j'ai dû manger du bon
monde autour de moi qui me permettent
d'aboutir les matches c'est des fois je
mets en boa l'antichambre avec mario
tremblay qui est mon bas des vins sanaa
proche de guy carbonneau puis on compte
de la marne à toute la game canadien a
faim dans le monde et à payer pour
écouter une game du canadien têtu et je
suis payé pour la matinée
carbo très honnêtement ça s'écrit pas si
on le peut dans le respect qu'on ne peut
toujours la même opinion opi puis les
lieux sont tellement généreux sont
tellement affreux honnêtement on ne
gagne incroyable activement lundi en ce
moment là je fais de la radio à 91,9 des
radios à québec faire des s
je trouve que tu trouveras puis je fais
le développement du soutien complet
jugement donne en journée mais
l'examen choix je reviens vraiment pas
de casse à la roche blanche ça c'est
quelque chose que tu vois c'est du long
terme ou belle lancée pendant
confinement puis c'est un job on
aimerait seule façon dont le cerveau
plus petit maxime va partir en europe
juillet-août dépendamment que c'est le
confinement mais moi je pense que c'est
un projet qui peut être là longtemps
parce que ce que j'aime c'est qu'on
parle pas d'actualité donc on n'est pas
garant de ce qui se passe aux canadiens
de ce noyau dur consentie ou ce que je
veux que tu me conte des histoires de
ton année 18 ainsi l'europe ont décru ce
lapin qui nous dit qu'ils sont aucun
savoir sont pas mes renner sont qu'un il
était prêt à ne pas saper d'être un
maillot de mu il y en a une qui est des
papin c'est magique
si l'aigle aujourd'hui c'est le bec la
plus de soin guy probablement plus
conscients de la ligue nationale mais
son premier camp d'entraînement
travaillait pas capable pour une cause à
mario chez ces malades
moi j'ai vécu ce même appareil que saku
koivu jouets sont mis à jouer motion
trio d'un match décalé que faisaient des
passes au jardin pratiquement pas
capable jusqu'à ce n'est pas tant un gym
et à son mariage il ya plein d'histoires
que les gentilles telle qu'on va compter
dans le poker comment les installer ce
n'est pas comme aujourd'hui ce dimanche
avec la crise les légumes ont changé
ryad ont changé c'est tout des arts
point qu'on veut compter puis même si tu
es là on a su martin brodeur que cela
d'après georges sim et on est fleuri 20
minutes là bas et on a dix toiles et
georges le racisme à l'eau qui menacent
sa coupe du président à grand baie free
bouillon à l'infini factice c'est ce que
j'aime dans ce projet là c'est qu'on
démontre un autre facette des
personnalités puis leur véhicule qui
montre que les gosses et pas juste des
robots c'est souvent on pense qu'ils
vont de 10 millions et d'un garçonnet
alors je m'excuse je suis arrivé sur le
jardin maison de joaillerie avec j'ai
des émotions s'agissait pas d'un côté on
veut montrer des des athlètes
on parlait pas tantôt justement en
écoutant les podcasts et georges
st-pierre et martin brac ce sont deux
légendes alors les conférences georges
on ne finit j'ai dit combien conduire la
conférence à petit j'en sais bien qu'ils
y moi vers chaque combat j'ai pas dis
moi dans mon but et j'avais tout j'avais
pas il fallait juste pour sa part à
l'époque les gens alors c'est ici
monsieur madame tout le monde va penser
ça maintenant deux mois que jury
national
mais moi ma réalité c'est quand je parle
à un martin brodeur a été induit esprit
que je me dis là même afin que les gens
du public doit penser de moi m'ont 15
gollum dissociant en moins c'est puis au
delà d'être tout l'aspect de du mental
qui georges était généreux et ici ce
soit l'autre partie du podcast qui
combinent pour qu'on va voir le jour j
espère avoir un jour chez beenox martin
brodeur pour une main sur 30 minutes
d'entrevue qui sont là qui se dévoile
qui donnent leur opinion tcc roth voici
une partie de leurs avoirs dont le
garder mais mais la générosité des gants
à ce moment depuis des bus on ne suit
pas la prendre sur soi on annonce la
prochaine unité pour le prochain show là
nous et on va s'en dit mardi et mardi la
semaine prochaine ouais ben ressortir
dans deux jours je n'en dis là qui aura
patron de la nasa soit parfait que non
aujourd'hui menacée sur laon sans vos
parties mènent ces saignées jeu mais ce
net regain international qui était
champion du bas-rhin de champion du
monde les frères champion du monde s'est
tué samedi cinq sens mais ne sont pas
les morts un récent chantier
harley et on a sorti des clips d'achille
en bonbons à sud soudan siècle c'est fou
dans la tête le camp vont parler d'un
extrait plus d'être rapide mais c'est
fou le sacco repris les autres pays
c'est de la chicane en paix sont deux
par la chistera qui coupe le chemin
malades pas compte tellement de chemin à
aller avec tipis ça s'anticipe au juste
du rock est un état d esprit on parle de
sir michael kingsbury on ne parle même
pas qu'on s'en voit un peu partout dans
au niveau des athlètes c'est le jura
après j'aimerais savoir des athlètes de
boxe m'a rien dit car qui butait des
premiers championnats intéressant si
sexy du monde sont sont généreux qui
sont énergiques sont plaisants vous
allez vous allez pas couvrir du tout le
le la ligue nationale quand ça va
repartir
non non je pense pour france peau parce
que je veux pas en même temps vous venez
faire compétition à ce que je fais pas
ce que je ferais si je prends mon
programme puis je m'envoie dit ce que je
dis ah non je parle lavage par la valeur
dans un sens par rapport à ce que je
fais bien mon employeur on veut pas
toucher à ce confrère ds oui oui ça se
peut qu'un choix et on donne notre
opinion sur brendan gallagher ça se peut
mais c'est pas le but chaud le but chaud
et pédaler dans l'actualité puis pas de
parler du jeu mieux parler de remy n'a
jamais parlé de développement je n'ai
pas l'édition de c'est toujours dans un
moment où on prend un petit frère ou
c'est pas un peu sonné surprise sans lui
notre troisième animateur un partenaire
exode des prochaines semaines
on laisse en suspens c'est un bon rebond
du trafic et challes
ah ouais ça intéresse à ce poste immo
ristic matin ben a accosté maurice tic
non tu vois des gars c'est quoi ça alors
c'est on essaie de trouver du japon
après l'annoncé par molex appui on a une
équipe
ainsi peu de temps comme chez beauty qui
nous en fait démarré mais c'est normal
surtout veiller sur zone le monde qu'ils
écoutent ou skis ou est ce qu'ils
pensent que oui ce qu'écoutent la poche
blois mais dans le fond long errant
dessus sur toutes les plateformes on y
lisait n'ont ni toit et e.on et facebook
ont instagram qui on va essayer de
donner du contenu différent sur nos
plateformes vont reprendre des entrevues
avec ont fait deux heures on va lui
couper par un plongeur schengen montre
inquiète demi ou autres qu'on va mettre
sur des plateformes pour que les gens
puissent voir un peu ce qu'on fait aussi
mais sinon c'est les jeudis soirs à 9
heures sur la page youtube de la poche
bleus à sousse a fait de l'espagne c'est
le meilleur non c'est le meilleur je
sais pas si tu as vu le poids maxi toys
story qui monte elle de la poche bleus à
la poche bleus on est en meeting ce pas
sérieux et que les gones marketing qui
l'a fait kiffer le
on est rentré qu'une succès les glaces
jean quéveau courriel guillaume malle
approche le point sur leurs gardes cac
cédant mais bon avec le de terre
française
si vous en voulez encore en faire un des
boss de la ph et d'amont la poche bleus
battus c'est ce système là dedans oui c
est ça a été créé par rapport au panier
bleu puis produits québécois mais pour
nous le double pour moi le double sens
et ça donne le temps ça donne le ton
c'est un petit mur estime humoristique
qui est léger qui plaisantent qu'on se
prend pas au sérieux
ada je pense que c'est ce que les jeunes
notamment d'anticiper pinottes notre
façon de juste de dévoiler comme celui
ci dont vous êtes à taverne les gens on
veut pas en avant depuis quelques années
les femmes merci beaucoup guillaume si
jamais vous avez un studio que toi qui
écris roi voilà c'est ce qu'on voit en
train de regarder tout ça pour après un
confinement
merci bon c'est l'invitation sasp un
coup merci merci à toi puis on écoute on
n'est que de la pole trophée oubliez pas
de commenter ces revenus du jeu de rôle
en instance à pékin